the Canon EOS R8 that was just announced
along with the R50 we had some Hands-On
time with it and I know a lot of you
were hoping for the R1 you're gonna have
to wait a little bit longer Canon is
building out their lower end lineup and
I'm actually glad they're doing this to
attract more photographers more
videographers who run a budget who don't
want to spend five six seven eight
thousand dollars on a camera system
sometimes you don't need to do that and
I'm glad Canon is building this part of
their camera lineup out and the R8 I
think is going to be a nice addition but
there's going to be some questions that
we're going to address that towards the
end of this video but first let's talk
about what the R8 is it's essentially
the baby sister or baby brother to the
R6 Mark II now it has so many
similarities I'm just going to tell you
what it doesn't have versus what the R6
Mark II does have okay because it has
pretty much the same performance
photography videography is exactly the
same what it doesn't have is an in-body
stabilization uh system inside of it has
electronic stabilization but it does not
have that actual physical stabilizer
system inside the camera it also does
not have a mechanical shutter that's
right it has electronic first curtain
and electronic shutter but no mechanical
shutter also the evf has less resolution
2.36 million dots versus 3.69 million
dots that's in the R6 Mark II also
there's no joystick on the back of the
R8 which the r62 has so you can maneuver
the focus Point around it does not have
it here on the R8 what else uh the
camera is lighter this is the lightest
full-frame camera on the market as Canon
is touting right now again we don't know
what's going to happen at CP Plus at the
end of February but as of today they're
touting it as the lightest full frame
camera on the market coming in at 461
grams 20 grams lighter than the RP which
it's replacing some people out there
were thinking this is going to replace
the EOS R it is not it is replacing the
RP this is a very light camera pills
really good in the hands in terms of
design it's very reminiscent of the R6
Mark II at first glance you're not going
to notice the difference unless you look
on the back as I mentioned minus the
joist sick and it may be a little bit
smaller I really couldn't tell much of a
difference but outside of that it feels
like an R6 Mark II the card slots card
slots we have we saw one Canon on their
spec sheet is touting too but we only
saw one one and maybe it could be a
Micro SD card we're not too sure anyway
we will find out what the actual answer
is because these were pre-production
cameras and some of the information we
have is not finalized and we'll let you
know by a pin comment and uh below this
video but as of right now it is a single
card slot the price point is coming in
at 2
398 Singapore dollars which is about
fifteen hundred dollars less than the
RSX Mark II I think this is a very
enticing offer good price point small
lightweight really good image quality
coming out of this camera both for
photos and for video as a matter of fact
Zaki had a heck of a time shooting
b-roll epic b-roll of this Chef cooking
this amazing lunch for us to test out
the camera because they want to give us
something to do instead of just you know
shooting walls so we have to shoot this
Chef making this beautiful French I
believe it was French
we had some other things anyway I mean
it was good lunch so check out this
b-roll and I'll come back with my final
thoughts on the R8
[Music]
thank you
oh Zacky
good this video is brought to you by
Asus check out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED
Space Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its space gray durability it
even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16 by 10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
as you saw right there the video quality
is actually really good out of this
camera system and it's the same as the
R6 Mark II you can only shoot in C log 3
or HDR PQ out of this you cannot shoot
in C log 2 which a lot of you do like
that's not going to happen in this but
you're still going to get good image
quality and if you use the standard
color profile it's not too bad a little
bit contrasty the same as I got out of
the R6 Mark II but it's definitely
usable again this is not going to be a
pro camera for people out there do not
try to make it a pro camera like the R6
Mark II that some of you out there were
trying to push Beyond its limits don't
do that with the R8 this is a backup
camera secondary camera or your first
full-frame camera system treat it as
such you want to go professional pay a
little bit more and go professional if
you want something nice easy lightweight
to carry in your bag this is a camera to
consider okay now let's talk about
another lens that they released actually
too one for full frame and one for aps-c
now the full frame is a 24 to 50 at 4.5
to 6.3 STM lens that's a lens that we
did try on this as well as the 51.2
which when you have a 51.2 you got to
try that lens the lenses but it's
friggin phenomenal I love that lens but
it costs a bomb it's like
two of these cameras but anyway it's a
good lens we um had some fun with that
and this 24 to 50 is a nice little kit
lens it's not that expensive and again
if you don't have a Canon system you're
looking to get into this that's a nice
lens to pick up to get you going and
even if you're going to be doing some
video that's a nice little lens you want
to shoot Outdoors you're gonna have to
stop down anywhere use an ND filter so
this aperture range is going to be okay
for me 4.5 to 6.3 that's going to be
more than ample but but again if you
want to get you know better image
quality you know better glass you're
gonna have to pay more that's how the
game is it's always been that way but
overall the lens did perform relatively
well and it's lightweight on the R8
which makes it a really nice camera to
take around with you now how does the R8
fit into what's out there currently on
the market because a lot of you will
probably be comparing this to the Lumix
S5 too that was just recently announced
coming in at us two thousand dollars
that does give you Ibis mechanical
shutter better video codecs and you
could arguably say that Panasonic now
has less expensive more enticing prime
lenses than what what Canon's offering
right now Canon is really concentrating
on zoom lenses at a lower price point
but Panasonic is giving other people
prime lenses 1.8 Etc et cetera that are
coming in at a really good price point
same with Nikon with the Z6 Mark II so
that makes this camera a really
interesting
um four-way for Canon how are they going
to compete in this Marketplace will it
work or will it won't now Canon saying
they are going to be building out their
lower end lens range very very soon so
hopefully this year we're going to see
more of that but right now they're
concentrating on their zooms because
they spine that those will be more
enticing for a lot of young
videographers and photographers that
want to get into the craft I understand
that and I do agree with it to some
extent but it's nice to have some primes
but I think it is going to be a very
interesting
um battle if you will with a lot of
these lower end cameras coming into 2023
because a lot of the technology that
we've been seeing in 2021 and 2022 is
creeping down into these cameras and
this technology is fantastic the
tracking the auto focusing all the great
attributes of the ra has are some even
better than what's in the R3 and in the
R5 that's currently on the market so it
does make it really enticing for a lot
of people out there and if you like
Canon glass you like Canon cameras this
is one camera to get I think it's easy
to use it's lightweight the image
quality is fantastic and you're gonna
get a lot of usage out of it and if you
ever want to let it go and move up to
something else there's gonna be someone
that's going to want to pick this camera
up B camera secondary camera definitely
in a heartbeat they'll pick this thing
up anyway those are my thoughts on the
Canon R8 again this was a pre-production
camera when we'd get a production camera
we'll probably be doing a full review on
it but I have to tell you based on what
I've seen right now it's working
fantastic I don't know how much better
they can improve the camera system by
it's really that good for what it is and
if it performs like the R6 Mark II which
I tried which it pretty much does it's
going to be a solid outing for Canon so
anyway if you like this video check out
more of our reviews right here
[Music]